andere haben vielleicht schon
pfingstferien aber was für eine
stressige wochen für unsere kanzlerin
für angela merkel überlegt noch heute
trifft sie putin gestern eu gipfel und
am mittwoch gab es einen regelrechten
showdown im bundestag generaldebatte
da geht es traditionell zur sache denn
die neue broker stellt ihren ersten
haushalt vor
das ist immer eine sternstunde des
parlamentarismus mit der stets gleichen
rollenverteilung die regierung sagt
sinngemäß alles supi haushaltslage
fantastisch laune sogar noch besser dann
haben wir unsere koalitionsvereinbarung
aber auch in einer stimmung
verabschiedet die uns sagt die stimmung
war auch nicht schlecht
es gab schnittchen
wir haben wird zu über seo frage nach
wie immer alles gut tatsächlich ist das
bei diesem general debatten immer
derselbe ablauf vom prinzip 18 mal
darauf die regierung behauptet
deutschland geht's bombig deutschland
geht es gold und da kommt irgendeine
gewitter ziegel von der opposition und
sagt so was wie deutschland tomysl stück
scheiße bitte das gibt es doch gar nicht
sie macht jetzt ein album zusammen mit
farid bang ja dann hat sich irgendwas
geblockt über kopftuch männer und messer
mädchen eine haushaltsdebatte frau weil
hat halt nur eine rede und olaf scholz
hatte seinen ersten großen auftritt als
finanzminister
quasi als beschützer unseres geldes das
ist ja die rolle ja wer olaf hier
verteidigt ab sofort die schwarze null
auf seine ganz spezielle norddeutsche
art
herr scholz manche ihrer kritiker sagen
ja ihre haushaltszahlen ihr plan ist so
dröge das auch gut von herrn schäuble
vorgelegt werden könnte
zunächst mal das ist mir ein bedürfnis
herrn minister schäuble in schutz zu
nehmen er ist nicht dröge
das ist eine falsche beurteilung die ich
nicht teile ja ich habe ja nur gesagt so
dröge wie sie das ist ja wohl nur
unverschämtheit
aber in der sache völlig richtig warum
wollte die spd eigentlich unbedingt das
finanzministerium wenn der scholz hier
einfach weitermacht wie sein vorgänger
es bleibt beim fette schwarze null
wenn nur das jetzt halt ist der einzige
unterschied
der bund investiert zwar 37 milliarden
aber das ist viel zu wenig und reicht
nicht mal ansatzweise um den verfall
unserer infrastruktur zu stoppen wir
leben von der substanz
es betrug an kommenden generationen es
ist ja ein geradezu idiotisches
menschenexperiment jetzt im zdf
schwarz-rot schulz das neue ihre tv
experiment was passiert wenn 82
millionen in einem land leben das jeden
tag kaputter wird macht das denn spaß
das dachte ich mir und so leben wir mit
den brücken von 1960 die im internet von
1990 und der kanzlerin von 2005
schwarz-rot scholz jetzt im zdf dem
einzigen sender dessen zuschauer noch
mehr oder sind als die a 3
oder sie geschlossen auf
ja
da sind wir stolz darauf das zdf hat die
besten alten zuschauer der welt begrüßte
alle die noch da sind hallo
ja und noch mal deutschland muss bringen
aufhören die riesige investitionslücke
vor sich herzuschieben wann wenn ich
jetzt in dieser bescheuerten niedrigzins
welt man sparen ist doch kein
selbstzweck man man spart doch nicht um
zu sparen ja ganz tragen und wissen man
müsste dafür nicht mal steuern erhöhen
einfach sinnlose subventionen streichen
und weniger klientelgeschenke vorwahlen
verteilen hallo mütter rente
wir brauchen kluge investitionen in
bildung und in zukunft allein für die
sanierung unserer kaputten deutschen
schulen bräuchten wir aktuell 33
milliarden nicht trampeln weil sonst
recht einschätzen können und dann als
bester ausbrechen kann
ja das war ne ansage gehört auch zu
trocken sonst bricht aus west aus
immerhin für die digitalisierung unserer
schulen werden jetzt von der groko 3,5
milliarden locker gemacht für die
digitalisierung meldet das löst zwar
nicht das eigentliche problem aber dann
können die schüler ihre neuen laptops
immerhin unter die wackligen tisch
schieben oder kaputte fensterscheiben
damit reparieren und natürlich ganz
wichtig als schutz wenn mal wieder der
putz runterkommt dem italy sierung die
zukunftsinvestition wisst ja beim
breitband hinken wir gnadenlos hinterher
im europäischen vergleich
dafür werden jetzt scheinbar die ersten
politiker durch roboter ersetzt als
gesetzgeber die in diesem haus ist
parlament wir werden uns da einbringen
und das ganze vor anschlägen
[Applaus]
was war da los
ja
android ist nur die beta-version wenn
alles hängt das sprachzentrum schwarze
null warum schwarze null wahrung
knausern bei bildung und infrastruktur
fakt ist es gibt keine überzeugenden
empirischen belege für die wirksamkeit
von sparpolitik sagt inzwischen sogar
der iwf trotzdem ziehen wir das eisern
durch man muss wahrscheinlich einfach
dran glauben
wie bei jeder anderen sekte auch wirte
schneider leitet die neu gegründete
heilig geist kirche zur sparsamen
jungfrau dort wird die schwarze null
regelrecht angebetet frau schneider
irritiert dass sie gar nicht dass
deutschland mit seinem spar- fetisch
international ziemlich isoliert ist
wissen sie was er welke
es gab schon einmal ein mann der
international ziemlich isoliert war
dieser mann hieß jesus denken sie da mal
drüber nach ja wir aber preisen heute
olaf scholz
liebe gemeinde
[Musik]
preise den hohler preise die er war
sozialdemokrat er war ein notorischer
geldverschwender doch heute kann er
wieder sehen
denn ihn erlöste die schwarze liste
[Musik]
so begab es sich in einer wüste hinter
hamburg das dem olaf der uralte prophet
wolfgang erschien und er erklärte dem
dummen sozen das wunder des sparens and
sparen ist wenn man weniger geld ausgibt
als man nicht hat du sagst weniger
ausgeben als du nicht hast doch überall
lauert die versuchung ja freunde auch
ich erlebe es dass ich in die stadt gehe
und bei deichmann oder görtz gibt es
schon wieder diese tollen riechen
sandaletten im angebot
aber dann nehme ich meine olaf scholz
geisel und sagen
weiche dämon des schreckens der renner
des konsums sich ja gut ist ja gut
selbst die sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen
also berater der bundesregierung sagen
bestimmte öffentliche investitionen sind
kein diebstahl an kommenden generationen
sondern sich im gegenteil später für
unsere kinder aus kinder dass sie alles
haben wollen diese kinder von heute
handys geöffnete schwimmbäder schulen
insulin verwöhnte plagen
ich habe will einen schlanken staat
einen ausgemergelten runtergehungert ein
staat der aussieht wie diese 14 jährigen
mädchen die in heidi klums prosieben
katar vor sich hin schmachten
[Musik]
halleluja heidi klum
wie kann man den roko fürs sparen feiern
der haushalt ist doch nur ausgeglichen
weil die konjunktur brummt und der staat
seit der finanzkrise 300 milliarden
weniger zinsen zahlen musste
die groko lesen haben in wirklichkeit
überhaupt nicht gespart chemie
er hatte schwarze null gelästert
verbrannten cat saß auf einem
scheiterhaufen aus bundesschatzbriefen
machen wir später davon jetzt öffnen wir
unsere sparbücher und singe lied nummer
412 kommen sparen wir alle weiter sparen
ganzen land
[Musik]
werner schreiber am montag
[Applaus]